At this point, lots of people have heard that mosques and Muslim businesses around New York City have been watched by undercover officers and informants. The Associated Press won the Pulitzer Prize for a series of articles documenting the extent of the surveillance by the New York Police Department-- 53 mosques, 8 Muslim student groups, and 263 so-called hot spots.
目前，很多人都听说过纽约市周围的清真寺和穆斯林企业受到了便衣警察和线人的监视。《美联社》因一系列记录纽约警察局监视程度的文章而获得了普利策奖——涉及53座清真寺、8个穆斯林学生团体和263个所谓的“热点地区”。
And people feel surveilled. Ramzi Kassem, a law professor who does workshops for Muslims to know their legal rights, says that when he gives the workshops at a mosque, often there's a sermon first. And occasionally--
人们感到被监视了。法学教授拉姆齐·卡塞姆（Ramzi Kassem）经常为穆斯林举办讲习班，帮助他们了解自己的合法权利。他说，当他在清真寺举办讲习班时，通常会先进行布道。有时——
That sermon kicks off with a preface that is explicitly intended for the informants in the room, where the spiritual leader is saying, if you're with the NYPD or you're with the FBI, welcome. We know you're here. We hope that you'll benefit and grow spiritually as a result of this sermon.
布道开场时会有一段序言，明确是针对房间里的线人，精神领袖会说：如果你是纽约警察局或联邦调查局的人，欢迎。我们知道你们在这里。我们希望你们能从这次布道中受益，并在精神上获得成长。
One Saturday night in Queens in a Muslim community center, the handwritten sign outside says, "Know Your Rights." Three dozen people show up. Their kids run around before it starts. Coffee in the back. It's a workshop run by Kassem and another lawyer, Diala Shamas, who work with a project called CLEAR from the City University of New York law school to give free legal aid to Muslims who get caught up in counter-terrorism surveillance investigations.
在皇后区的一个穆斯林社区中心，一个周六晚上，门外的告示牌上手写着“了解你的权利”。来了三打人。讲习班开始前，孩子们在跑来跑去。后面有咖啡。这是由卡塞姆和另一位律师迪亚拉·沙马斯（Diala Shamas）举办的讲习班，他们与纽约城市大学法学院的一个名为CLEAR的项目合作，为那些陷入反恐监视调查的穆斯林提供免费法律援助。
What we are here to talk about today is what many of you have either experienced or heard about, and that's the situation where you have officers from the NYPD Intelligence division that show up, for example, at your home dressed in plainclothes, or FBI agents that show up at your home, at your masjid, at your place of work. And they start asking you questions about who you know, what the imam said at the mosque on Friday, what your political views are, what websites you visit.
我们今天在这里要谈论的是你们许多人曾经经历过或听说过的事情，那就是纽约警察局情报部门的便衣警官出现在你们家门口，或者联邦调查局（FBI）特工出现在你们家、清真寺或工作场所的情况。他们开始问你关于你认识谁、伊玛目在清真寺周五说了什么、你的政治观点是什么、你访问了哪些网站的问题。
Kassem and Shamas told me that sometimes they ask for a show of hands at these workshops, and they learn that every single person in the room has either been visited by law enforcement like this or know somebody who has.
卡塞姆和沙马斯告诉我，有时他们会在讲习班上要求大家举手，然后发现房间里的每一个人要么曾经受到过执法部门这样的拜访，要么认识受到过此类拜访的人。
So what we want to do today is nothing controversial. We just want to arm you with the knowledge of your rights so that you know how to respond when you find yourself-- if you find yourself, [SPEAKING ARABIC]-- in that really uncomfortable situation where you have an FBI agent at your door or an NYPD detective at your workplace, asking to talk to you.
所以我们今天想做的并不具有争议性。我们只是想用关于你们权利的知识武装你们，以便当你们发现自己——如果你发现自己，[阿拉伯语]——处于那种非常不舒服的情况下，当有FBI探员在你家门口或纽约警察局侦探在你的工作场所要求与你谈话时，知道如何应对。
The two attorneys start with a demonstration of what happens in one of these encounters. Diala Shamas plays the plainclothes FBI agent who comes to the door. Kassem plays the guy at home.
两位律师首先演示了在这种遭遇中会发生什么。迪亚拉·沙马斯扮演来到门口的便衣FBI探员。卡塞姆扮演在家的男人。
We're first going to do it the wrong way. This is how this interaction should not happen.
我们首先要以错误的方式来演示。这就是这种互动不应该发生的方式。
Knock, knock.
敲门声。
Yes? Hello.
是的？你好。
Hi. Is this Ramzi Kassem's house?
嗨。这是拉姆齐·卡塞姆的家吗？
Yeah, this is me.
是的，是我。
Great. Can I just come in?
太好了。我可以进去吗？
Sure. Of course. Yeah, come in, please.
当然。当然。请进。
Thanks.
谢谢。
Who are you? I'm sorry, I didn't--
你是谁？抱歉，我没有——
Oh, I'm-- My name is Diala. I'm with the FBI. I'm just here to ask you a couple questions.
哦，我是——我叫迪亚拉。我是FBI的。我只是来问你几个问题。
Oh, wow. FBI. OK. Sure.
哦，哇。FBI。好的。当然。
Nothing to worry about. Just a standard, you know, we're getting to know the neighborhood. I'm new here, so--
没什么可担心的。只是常规的，你知道，我们正在熟悉这个社区。我是新来的，所以——
Later, in the discussion afterwards, the audience points out that this was a mistake. He should have asked for ID before letting the FBI agent into his home. And he doesn't have to answer any questions. He could have even asked for a warrant. The crowd also points out that he seems very nervous-- another mistake.
后来，在随后的讨论中，观众指出这是一个错误。他在让FBI探员进家门之前应该要求查看身份证件。而且他不必回答任何问题。他甚至可以要求查看搜查令。人群还指出他看起来非常紧张——这是另一个错误。
So do you go to that mosque down the street?
那你去街那头的那个清真寺吗？
Yes, Dardal?
是的，Dardal清真寺吗？
Dardal? Yeah. Yeah. OK, and who's the imam there?
Dardal？是的。好的，那里的伊玛目是谁？
Um, what-- why are you--?
呃，为什么你要——？
Oh, I'm just curious. You know, it's part of my-- I just want to make sure that I say the right thing when I meet the right people.
哦，我只是好奇。你知道，这是我的——我只是想确保我在见到合适的人时能说对话。
Oh, OK. Yeah, he's been the imam there for a number of years, and he's from Egypt. I can't remember his name.
哦，好的。是的，他在那里当伊玛目很多年了，他来自埃及。我不记得他的名字了。
OK. You can't remember his name?
好的。你不记得他的名字？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
Oh, OK. So is it Mr. Abu Jamil?
哦，好的。那是阿布·贾米尔先生吗？
Um, no-- I don't think that's him. He's one of-- he's one of the leaders. He's one of the organizers there.
呃，不——我不认为是他。他是——他是那里的领导之一。他是那里的组织者之一。
The agent asks who else lives in the house. She asks, what does he think about the political situation in Egypt?
探员问还有谁住在这个家里。她问，他怎么看埃及的政治局势？
Do you-- do you have an ID?
你有——你有身份证吗？
Yeah. Yeah, sure. Sure, here's my ID.
是的。好的，当然。给你，这是我的身份证。
They talk a little more about politics. The agent thanks him for his cooperation, says she may come back with more questions.
他们又谈论了一些关于政治的话题。探员感谢他的配合，说她可能会回来问更多问题。
OK.
好的。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Thank you, Agent.
谢谢，探员。
Have a good day.
祝你今天愉快。
You too.
你也是。
Now--
现在——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
You should not be applauding that performance.
你们不应该为那场表演鼓掌。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What went wrong in this?
那场戏里什么出错了？
[INAUDIBLE] there was a lot of volunteering information [INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]那里有很多自愿提供信息的行为 [听不清]。
So the brother's pointing out that there was a lot of volunteering of information.
那位兄弟指出，有很多自愿提供信息的行为。
So it's difficult, right? Because I was being sort of friendly. And why wouldn't you volunteer that information if you don't think that you've done anything wrong? I was just asking a couple of seemingly benign questions, just trying to get to know the neighborhood.
所以这很困难，对吧？因为我当时表现得比较友好。如果你认为自己没做错什么，为什么不自愿提供那些信息呢？我只是问了几个看似无害的问题，只是想熟悉一下社区。
And the only problem with that, the two lawyers tell the crowd, is that the more you say, the more you could accidentally be incriminating yourself. Especially dangerous, they say, were those moments in the demonstration where Kassem was nervously stumbling around, not sure what to say, trying to remember.
两位律师告诉人群，其中唯一的问题是，你说得越多，就越可能意外地自证其罪。他们说，特别危险的是演示中卡塞姆紧张地支支吾吾、不确定说什么、试图回忆的那些时刻。
--more specific. Under federal law in the United States, lying to a federal agent is a federal offense. It's a crime. And it's a crime that's being charged since 9/11 disproportionately against Muslims.
——更具体一点。在美国联邦法律下，对联邦探员撒谎是联邦罪行。这是一种犯罪。而且自9/11事件以来，这种罪名被不成比例地指控针对穆斯林。
So the moment that you have that interaction with the federal agent-- let's say I didn't remember something. Diala asks me a question-- oh, you're friends with Cyrus? Where were you last Tuesday? And I say, oh, I think we were camping.
所以当你与联邦探员发生互动的那一刻——假设我不记得某件事了。迪亚拉问我一个问题——哦，你是赛勒斯的朋友吗？上周二你在哪儿？我说，哦，我想我们去露营了。
But maybe she spoke to Cyrus before, and Cyrus said something different. So all of a sudden, there's a discrepancy. Either I'm in trouble or Cyrus in trouble. And so even having that very basic conversation--
但也许她之前和赛勒斯谈过，而赛勒斯说了些不一样的话。所以突然之间，出现了不一致。要么我有麻烦，要么赛勒斯有麻烦。所以即使是进行那种非常基本的对话——
Because of this, he tells the group over and over, he says this-- if the FBI or NYPD comes around asking these general questions, it is best to get a lawyer.
正因为如此，他一遍又一遍地告诉小组，他这样说——如果FBI或纽约警察局来问这些一般性问题，最好找律师。
We're not saying never talk to them. That's not what we're saying. What we're saying is do it in a way that is responsible. And the only way you do that is by bringing in someone that can help you even out the balance of power, so you don't do it at a disadvantage. You're not an untrained civilian talking to trained FBI interrogators who know the law and you do not know the law.
我们不是说永远不要和他们说话。我们不是那个意思。我们所说的是，以一种负责任的方式去做。而你做到这一点的唯一方法就是带上一个可以帮你平衡权力的人，这样你就不会处于劣势。你不是一个未受训练的平民在与受过训练的FBI审讯官交谈，他们懂法律，而你不懂法律。
This lesson does not go down easily with everybody here. Somebody brings up the question of what to do when an officer on the street asks to search your handbag. A man says, well, if you have nothing to hide, let them do it. A woman says, if I say no, it'll just make them more suspicious of me. Another man says, in these situations he doesn't want to do anything that might antagonize them.
这个教训在这里并没有让每个人都容易接受。有人提出了一个问题：当街上的警察要求搜查你的手提包时该怎么办。一个人说，好吧，如果你没有什么可隐瞒的，让他们搜吧。一位女士说，如果我拒绝，只会让他们对我更怀疑。另一名男子说，在这种情况下，他不想做任何可能激怒他们的事情。
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
What the gentleman here was saying is, these are basically really tense situations and you don't want to aggravate the agent, you don't want to offend them, you don't want to be-- you don't want the situation to escalate. So be polite, but be firm.
这位先生刚才说的是，这些基本上是非常紧张的情况，你不想激怒探员，不想冒犯他们，不想让情况升级。所以要礼貌，但要坚定。
Don't be like me. As you all saw, I wasn't confident. I was very nervous. I let her run all over me.
不要像我一样。正如你们所看到的，我当时并不自信。我非常紧张。我让她完全压制了我。
But you can be polite, you can be firm, and you can exercise your right. And it's nothing controversial. It's what Martha Stewart does. When she was approached by the FBI, she didn't talk to them directly. She retained lawyers. When President Clinton was under investigation, he had a team of lawyers.
但你可以礼貌，可以坚定，并且可以行使你的权利。这没什么争议。这就是玛莎·斯图尔特（Martha Stewart）的做法。当她被FBI接触时，她没有直接和他们说话。她聘请了律师。当克林顿总统接受调查时，他有一个律师团队。
So that's the safe, responsible way to do it. And it's not being uncooperative. It's actually the most American thing to do.
所以这才是安全、负责任的做法。这并不是不合作。这实际上是最“美国”的做法。
It's an uneasy time between some Muslim communities and law enforcement right now. Kassem and Shamas do a whole workshop on what to do if you think that there's an undercover informant infiltrating your mosque or student group. They say maybe 10 times this past year, some group has come to them with that worry.
目前一些穆斯林社区与执法部门之间的关系处于紧张时期。卡塞姆和沙马斯专门举办了一个关于如果你认为有卧底线人渗透进你的清真寺或学生团体时该怎么办的讲习班。他们说在过去的一年里，大约有10次，有团体带着这种担忧来找他们。
It's hard for some people not to feel a little paranoid. And if you can't imagine how somebody gets to that point, what the experience is that drives you there, we have a story today about what happened at one mosque where an undercover informant went in and things seemed to go very badly wrong. Not just from the point of view of the congregation. The informant is not happy about how it worked out, and we presume the FBI can't be too pleased, either. They've alienated the very people in the Muslim community who wanted to work with them. Beyond all that, it's a compelling and very weird case.
有些人很难不感到有点偏执。如果你无法想象一个人是如何达到那种地步的，是什么样的经历驱使他们到那一步的，我们今天有一个故事，关于在一家清真寺发生的事情，一名卧底线人潜入，事情似乎变得非常糟糕。不仅仅是从会众的角度来看。线人对结果也不满意，我们推测FBI也一定不会太高兴。他们疏远了穆斯林社区中那些本想与他们合作的人。除此之外，这还是一个引人入胜且非常离奇的案件。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》（This American Life），由公共广播国际（PRI）分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续关注我们。
Act one-- Gym Rat. So a caveat before we start this-- although the tactics used by the FBI in this story are tactics that they use in other cases, this story is not about how things typically go in an FBI investigation. This is an outlier. It is a cautionary tale. Is a case where we can watch everything go wrong.
第一幕——健身狂（Gym Rat）。在我们开始之前先提个醒——尽管这个故事中FBI使用的策略在其他案件中也使用过，但这个故事并非关于FBI调查中通常发生的情况。这是一个个例。这是一个警示故事。是一个我们可以目睹一切出错的案例。
It happened in California, in Orange County, in 2006. And at that point, at least one homegrown terrorist had come out of an Orange County mosque and gone to work with Osama bin Laden, was on the FBI's most wanted terrorist list. And relations between the FBI and Muslims in Orange County, California were already on edge before this story began.
它发生在加利福尼亚州的奥兰治县，2006年。在那时，至少有一名本土恐怖分子从奥兰治县的一家清真寺出来，去为奥萨马·本·拉登工作，当时在FBI的通缉恐怖分子名单上。在这个故事开始之前，奥兰治县FBI与穆斯林之间的关系就已经处于紧张状态。
So on edge that the head of the FBI for Los Angeles, Stephen Tidwell, decided they should do a town meeting at a mosque in Orange County. It was the Islamic Center of Irvine, where he said emphatically that the FBI was not monitoring Muslim student groups in the area or the mosque itself. The crowd did not buy this. Somebody in the audience told Tidwell that it would be naive for them to believe that the FBI was not monitoring the mosque. Everyone should understand that they were being monitored, he said. Tidwell interrupted-
紧张到洛杉矶FBI负责人史蒂芬·蒂德韦尔（Stephen Tidwell）决定在奥兰治县的一家清真寺举行一次城镇会议。那是尔湾伊斯兰中心（Islamic Center of Irvine），他在会上明确表示，FBI没有监视该地区的穆斯林学生团体或该清真寺本身。人群并不相信这一点。观众中的某个人告诉蒂德韦尔，如果他们相信FBI没有监视清真寺，那将是幼稚的。他说，每个人都应该明白他们正在被监视。蒂德韦尔打断说——
Look-- one. No, you're not.
看——第一。不，你们没有。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
If we're going to come to mosques to come to service, we will tell you we're coming to service.
如果我们打算来清真寺参加礼拜，我们会告诉你们我们来参加礼拜。
MAN 1:  You will send your agents without anybody knowing.
男子1：你们会派特工去，而不让任何人知道。
The man in the audience replied, you will send your agents without anybody knowing.
观众中的那名男子回答说：你们会派特工去，而不让任何人知道。
But what I'm saying, FBI, we will tell you we're coming, for the very reason we don't want you to think you're being monitored.
但我说的是，FBI，我们会告诉你们我们要来，正是因为我们不想让你们认为你们正在被监视。
That was June 5, 2006. As best as we can determine from people at the mosque and from testimony in court, two months after Tidwell reassured them that the FBI would not monitor them without telling them, the FBI placed an undercover informant in the mosque. And this is where our story begins. Sam Black is our reporter.
那是2006年6月5日。根据我们能从清真寺的人和法庭证词中确定出的情况，在蒂德韦尔向他们保证FBI不会在不告知的情况下监视他们两个月后，FBI在清真寺里安插了一名卧底线人。这就是我们故事开始的地方。萨姆·布莱克（Sam Black）是我们的记者。
The informant in this story is named Craig Monteilh, and like a lot of people who go undercover to catch criminals, he used to be a criminal himself. He's done time for forging checks, embezzlement, and grand theft. At one point, he made a living stealing cocaine from drug dealers. As I reported this story, people who know him described him as a snake, a chameleon, a thug scam artist, and quote, "a piece of [BLEEP]."
这个故事里的线人名叫克雷格·蒙泰尔（Craig Monteilh），和许多去卧底抓捕罪犯的人一样，他自己曾经也是个罪犯。他因伪造支票、贪污和重大盗窃罪入狱过。有一次，他以从毒贩那里偷窃可卡因为生。在我报道这个故事时，认识他的人形容他是一条蛇、变色龙、恶棍骗子，以及引用的话说，“一块[脏话]”。
And Craig says some pretty far-fetched things, like this list of aliases. He told me he used all of these in undercover stings.
而且克雷格说了一些非常牵强的事情，比如这份化名名单。他告诉我他在卧底行动中使用了所有这些名字。
Italian drug dealer Vincent Donado. A Russian hitman by the name of Ivan Chernyenko. Colombian drug dealer Pedro Hernandez. A Bulgarian drug dealer by the name of Sergei Gurd. Also, I went by Polish names. One was Lech Vlesky.
意大利毒贩文森特·多纳多（Vincent Donado）。名叫伊万·切尔年科（Ivan Chernyenko）的俄罗斯杀手。哥伦比亚毒贩佩德罗·埃尔南德斯（Pedro Hernandez）。名叫谢尔盖·古尔德（Sergei Gurd）的保加利亚毒贩。此外，我还用过波兰名字。其中一个是莱赫·弗莱斯基（Lech Vlesky）。
It's unclear if any of these are real. But some of the unlikely things Craig says do check out, like the fact that he worked on a counter-terrorism operation for the FBI. The Bureau has confirmed this. In 2006, the FBI enlisted him to go undercover to catch people who were recruiting and training terrorists.
目前尚不清楚其中任何一个是真实的。但克雷格说的一些不太可能的事情确实属实，比如他确实为FBI执行过反恐行动的事实。联邦调查局已经证实了这一点。2006年，FBI招募他去卧底，以抓捕那些招募和训练恐怖分子的人。
Craig says it all began at a strip mall Starbucks, where he met with two FBI agents, Paul Allen and Kevin Armstrong. He says they told them they wanted him to go undercover. They'd pay him to infiltrate the Muslim community in Orange County. Which is a funny thought, because Craig's not the most inconspicuous guy.
克雷格说这一切始于一家商场的星巴克，在那里他会见了两位FBI探员，保罗·艾伦（Paul Allen）和凯文·阿姆斯特朗（Kevin Armstrong）。他说他们告诉他他们想让他去卧底。他们会付钱让他渗透进奥兰治县的穆斯林社区。这是一个有趣的想法，因为克雷格并不是最不显眼的那种人。
I'm 6'2", 260 pounds. It's not fat. It's lean body mass. I bench 500 pounds. I have 21 and 1/2-inch arms.
我身高6英尺2英寸，体重260磅。这不是肥胖。是精瘦体质。我卧推500磅。我有21.5英寸粗的手臂。
But according to Craig, the FBI wanted to use his lean body mass to their advantage.
但根据克雷格的说法，FBI想利用他的精瘦体质为他们服务。
I was to lure Muslim males into the gym using my physique to see what actually is the real pulse of the Muslim community. They told me what I did was vital to America's national security, and to do exactly what they said.
我被派去利用我的体格诱导穆斯林男性去健身房，看看穆斯林社区真正的脉搏到底是什么。他们告诉我，我的所作所为对于美国的国家安全至关重要，要完全按照他们说的做。
And did they have particular targets in the Muslim community in mind?
他们心目中有特定的穆斯林社区目标吗？
No. They said the targets would come to me.
没有。他们说目标会自己找上门来。
The FBI wouldn't talk to me for this story because the operation is still classified and because it's the subject of a lawsuit. But the FBI later confirmed in court that Craig was an undercover informant. A district attorney also stated in court that Craig did work with Agent Kevin Armstrong, and that Craig had given the FBI, quote, "very, very valuable information." The FBI also confirmed one other thing-- the name of Craig's operation.
FBI不会为了这个故事与我交谈，因为该行动仍属机密，且是一项诉讼的对象。但FBI后来在法庭上证实克雷格确实是一名卧底线人。一位地方检察官也在法庭上陈述说，克雷格确实与凯文·阿姆斯特朗探员共事，并且克雷格向FBI提供了“非常有价值的信息”。FBI还证实了另一件事——克雷格行动的代号。
Operation Flex. F-L-E-X.
“Flex”行动。F-L-E-X。
One Thursday in August 2006, Craig showed up at the Islamic Center of Irvine, one of the biggest mosques in Orange County, and met with the imam there. Craig told him that he wanted to convert to Islam. The next day after Friday prayers, Craig stood on a stage in front of hundreds of people and declared that he was now a Muslim, with a new Muslim name-- Farouk al-Aziz. People who were in the mosque that day remember it well, the first time they saw this new convert, Farouk.
2006年8月的一个星期四，克雷格出现在奥兰治县最大的清真寺之一——尔湾伊斯兰中心，并与那里的伊玛目见了面。克雷格告诉他，他想改信伊斯兰教。第二天周五礼拜后，克雷格站在数百人面前的台上，宣布他现在是一名穆斯林，拥有一个新的穆斯林名字——法鲁克·阿齐兹（Farouk al-Aziz）。那天在清真寺的人们记得很清楚，他们第一次看到这个新皈依者法鲁克的样子。
Picture, like, a 300-pound linebacker that has a ridiculously wide frame and then huge, massive legs.
想象一下，就像一个300磅的后卫，有着极其宽阔的骨架，然后是巨大的、粗壮的腿。
His biceps were just, like, my whole thigh, basically. He was a big guy.
他的二头肌基本上就是我的整个大腿。他是个大块头。
At the beginning, I was kind of, you know, kind of scared from him. [LAUGHS] He was kind of scary, to me, looking.
一开始，我有点，你知道，有点怕他。[笑] 对我来说，他看起来有点吓人。
Over the next few weeks, Craig started showing up at the nearby 24 Hour Fitness, a gym where a lot of the guys from the Irvine Mosque would work out. And when he wasn't at the gym, he was at the mosque. He attended prayer five times a day. One of the people who noticed Craig was an Egyptian guy named Ayman. He asked that I not use his last name.
在接下来的几周里，克雷格开始出现在附近的24小时健身房，很多尔湾清真寺的人都会去那里锻炼。当他不在健身房时，他就在清真寺。他每天五次参加礼拜。注意到克雷格的人之一是一个名叫艾曼（Ayman）的埃及人。他要求我不要使用他的姓氏。
Every day you would see him in the mosque. Every day you would see him. But he would be sitting alone. You don't know if he has friends or if he's struggling to understand what's going on. You feel bad. This guy, he's new to Islam. Probably either he's afraid or curious or something. I don't know. You don't know. You just want to be as friendly as you can.
每天你都能在清真寺看到他。每天都能看到。但他总是独自坐着。你不知道他是否有朋友，或者他是否在努力理解正在发生的事情。你会感到难过。这家伙，他是伊斯兰教的新手。可能要么他很害怕，要么很好奇之类的。我不知道。你不知道。你只是想尽可能友好。
Ayman lived in a house just around the corner from the mosque with a few other Egyptians. One day, he decided to introduce himself to Craig.
艾曼和另外几个埃及人住在离清真寺转角处的一所房子里。有一天，他决定向克雷格自我介绍。
I believe it was after the Dhuhr prayer, which is the one at 1 o'clock. I went to him and I said, hey, salaam alaikum, peace upon you, basically. And, hey, my name's Ayman.
我相信是在晌礼（Dhuhr prayer）之后，也就是下午1点那次。我走到他身边说，嘿，愿和平与你同在， basically。然后，嘿，我叫艾曼。
He says, it's been about four weeks, right? You're still here.
他说，已经过去大约四周了，对吧？你还在。
Craig remembered this too.
克雷格也记得这件事。
I said yes. He said, well, usually people just, new converts, after a few weeks they leave. They fall by the wayside. I said, well, not me. I'm a real Muslim.
我说是的。他说，好吧，通常人们只是，新皈依者，几周后就离开了。他们半途而废。我说，好吧，我不是。我是个真正的穆斯林。
And I told him, here's my number. And I wrote my number on a piece of paper. If you have any question about anything, like in your head about the religion, or if you need anything that I can help you with, I would love to.
然后我告诉他，这是我的电话。我把号码写在了一张纸上。如果你对任何事情有什么疑问，比如你脑子里对宗教有什么问题，或者如果你需要什么我能帮忙的地方，我很乐意。
He said, well, we're Egyptian. We get together after prayer on Fridays and during the weekends, and we all barbecue, have food together. Maybe you can come by and we'll talk to you more about your faith and how you can grow as a Muslim. From there, when I went home, I thought, I'm really in.
他说，好吧，我们是埃及人。我们周五和周末礼拜后聚在一起，我们都烧烤，一起吃东西。也许你可以过来，我们会和你谈谈你的信仰以及你如何能作为一名穆斯林成长。从那时起，当我回家时，我想，我真的进去了。
Craig's new friend Ayman lived with four unmarried Egyptian men, all in their late 20s or early 30s. One was an accountant. Another worked for a logistics company. There was a guy who worked in pharmaceuticals and an IT consultant. They each traveled occasionally, sometimes for work or sometimes back home to Egypt. Craig says his FBI handlers suspected the roommates might be a terrorist cell that would radicalize him, so he arrived at their house ready for anything.
克雷格的新朋友艾曼与四个未婚埃及男子住在一起，他们都二十多岁或三十出头。一个是会计。另一个在物流公司工作。有一个人在制药行业工作，还有一个是IT顾问。他们每个人偶尔都会旅行，有时是为了工作，有时是回埃及老家。克雷格说他的FBI处理员怀疑这几个室友可能是一个恐怖主义小组，会使他激进化，所以他去他们家时准备好了一切。
Well, first of all, they made some Egyptian food, which was very good. Delicious food. And we sat on the couch for about maybe a couple of hours, just had conversation. And they would play their Xbox while we're having conversation in a very competitive way.
嗯，首先，他们做了一些埃及食物，非常棒。美味的食物。我们坐在沙发上聊了大概几个小时。当我们在聊天时，他们会以一种非常竞争的方式玩Xbox。
I was engaged at the time, but I used to play more Xbox than spending time with my fiancee. It's, like, 80% Xbox, and everything else comes second.
我当时订婚了，但我玩Xbox的时间比陪未婚妻的时间多。大概80%的时间都在玩Xbox，其他一切都是次要的。
That's Ayman again. He and his friends were ridiculously obsessed with Xbox. They'd play tournaments for five hours a day, and they only played one game.
那是艾曼。他和他的朋友们对Xbox简直着迷。他们每天玩锦标赛五个小时，而且只玩一个游戏。
FIFA Soccer. That was the only thing. We played a lot of FIFA . We still play a lot of FIFA .
《国际足联足球》（FIFA Soccer）。只有那个。我们玩了很多《FIFA》。我们现在还在玩很多《FIFA》。
Yasser AbdelRahim was one of Ayman's roommates, a tall athletic guy who worked as a tech consultant. He'd lived in the US for about 10 years. Yassir and Ayman considered their house a brotherhood, but as he told me and my producer Brian Reed, not really the militant terror cell kind Craig was looking for.
亚瑟·阿卜杜勒拉希姆（Yasser AbdelRahim）是艾曼的室友之一，一个高大健壮的家伙，担任技术顾问。他在美国生活了大约10年。亚瑟和艾曼认为他们的房子是一个兄弟会，但正如他告诉我和我的制片人布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）的那样，并不是克雷格正在寻找的那种好战恐怖小组。
We'd all just hang out together, and a lot of my friends would actually kind of come in and say, this is kind of like the frat house, right? But obviously, we didn't drink, so--
我们只是聚在一起，很多我的朋友实际上会走进来，说，这就像个兄弟会房子，对吧？但显然，我们不喝酒，所以——
A frat house without alcohol.
一个没有酒精的兄弟会房子。
A kosher frat house, yes. [LAUGHS]
一个犹太洁食风格（kosher）的兄弟会房子，是的。[笑]
Craig's plan worked. Yassir and Ayman started inviting him over more and more. They'd hang out together, get coffee, go to the movies. When Craig got sick, they went to his house to keep him company. They bought him books about Islam and brought him back gifts from their trips to Egypt. Here's Ayman and then Yassir.
克雷格的计划成功了。亚瑟和艾曼开始越来越多地邀请他过去。他们聚在一起，喝咖啡，看电影。克雷格生病时，他们去他家陪他。他们给他买关于伊斯兰教的书，并从埃及旅行回来给他带礼物。这是艾曼和亚瑟的声音。
He was a super cool guy. You know, he'd initiate conversation, we'd talk about stuff.
他是个超级酷的人。你知道，他会主动发起对话，我们会谈论各种事情。
But he was very comfortable around us. He was very cool around us. He would joke around. He would tell us about what he did, some of the issues that he was going through. He said he was going through some rough patches from a family perspective, going through a divorce.
但他和我们在一起时感到非常自在。他和我们在一起时非常酷。他会开玩笑。他会告诉我们他的经历，他正在经历的一些问题。他说他从家庭角度来看正在经历一些艰难时期，正在经历离婚。
We tried not to speak in Arabic as much when he was around, because we didn't want to give him any feeling that he's uncomfortable, anything like that.
当他在场时，我们尽量少说阿拉伯语，因为我们不想让他觉得不舒服，诸如此类的事情。
We talked about the gym. We went and worked out together.
我们谈论健身房。我们一起去锻炼。
You know, obviously, when you see a big bulky guy, you know what I mean, that's just, like, very cool. I barely can lift five pounds.
你知道，显然，当你看到一个大块头的时候，你懂我的意思，这真的很酷。我几乎提不动五磅的东西。
We watched TV or sometimes we'd watch Arabic movies, because he'd be interested in actually seeing some of that.
我们看电视，有时看阿拉伯电影，因为他实际上对看这些很有兴趣。
We never treated him as an outsider.
我们从未把他当作局外人。
He seemed like one of the boys.
他看起来就像我们的一员。
But Craig was at work-- watching, taking notes, and recording with a hidden microphone.
但克雷格在工作——在观察、做记录，并用隐藏的麦克风录音。
It'd be on the whole day. I would get into my car in my garage, I would turn on the device, and I would say something like, Farouk Al-Aziz, May 4, 2012, 5:45 AM, and I am hot. Meaning, it's beginning.
它整天开着。我会坐进车库里的车里，打开设备，然后说一些类似“法鲁克·阿齐兹，2012年5月4日，凌晨5:45，我很热（I am hot）”的话。意思是，开始了。
The FBI has publicly confirmed that Craig recorded audio and video during this operation. That means, presumably, the smack the Egyptians talked during Xbox tournaments, the discussions of movies and their personal lives, the exercise tips that Craig gave them at the gym.
FBI已公开证实克雷格在此行动中录制了音频和视频。这意味着，大概，埃及人在Xbox锦标赛中谈论的垃圾话，关于电影和他们个人生活的讨论，克雷格在健身房给他们的运动建议都被录了下来。
The Egyptians would play pickup soccer on the weekends with a bunch of other Muslim guys. Craig went to some of these games, but he never played. Instead, Craig says he used the opportunity to jot down license plate numbers and film the game so his handlers could see who associated with whom. According to Craig, he also brought his handlers things from the Egyptians' house that might have their DNA or fingerprints.
埃及人周末会和其他一些穆斯林小伙子一起踢足球。克雷格去过几次比赛，但他从不踢。相反，克雷格说他利用这个机会记下车牌号码并拍摄比赛，以便他的处理员能看到谁与谁交往。据克雷格说，他还给他的处理员带去了可能带有埃及人DNA或指纹的东西。
They instructed me to get, because Ayman smoked, a cigarette butt from his ash tray in his room, and certain items from his bathroom, like a toothpaste tube.
他们指示我获取——因为艾曼抽烟——他房间烟灰缸里的烟蒂，以及他浴室里的某些物品，比如牙膏管。
So you would sneak around their house and steal these things from their rooms?
所以你会偷偷溜进他们的房子，从他们的房间里偷这些东西？
Yes.
是的。
Meeting Ayman and Yassir, it was hard to imagine why the FBI was monitoring them. They just seemed like normal guys. The FBI, of course, wouldn't talk about the case. And they wouldn't even talk in a general way, separate from this case, about how they choose who they're going to investigate.
见到艾曼和亚瑟，很难想象为什么FBI在监视他们。他们看起来只是普通的家伙。当然，FBI不会谈论此案。他们甚至不会以一般方式（与此案无关）谈论他们如何选择调查对象。
So I called Trevor Aaronson to help me make sense of Operation Flex. He's an investigative journalist who's analyzed over 500 FBI terrorism convictions, looking at how informants are used to find suspects, surveil them, and build cases. I told Trevor what Craig said, that the FBI went into the Muslim community without any specific suspects. Trevor said that's possible, but it's also possible that Craig wasn't told who the targets were.
所以我打电话给特雷弗·阿伦森（Trevor Aaronson）帮我理清“Flex”行动。他是一位调查记者，分析了超过500起FBI恐怖主义定罪案件，研究了如何利用线人来寻找嫌疑人、监视他们并建立案件。我告诉特雷弗克雷格说的话，说FBI在没有任何特定嫌疑人的情况下进入了穆斯林社区。特雷弗说这有可能，但也可能克雷格并不知道谁是目标。
It's possible that the FBI had information that Craig isn't aware of. In the cases we've looked at, it's really uncommon that the FBI would spend lots of time with someone who was so unfruitful. If they're spending months and months and all they're doing is playing soccer, the FBI will move on. If Craig was spending that much time with them, it's worth noting that most likely they had enough for what they call a predicate, which is a reason that they were investigating them. You know, that there was a phone call that was overheard, or there was some kind of correspondence with someone overseas that the FBI is monitoring that made the FBI agents suspicious of this particular group.
FBI可能掌握了克雷格不知道的信息。在我们调查过的案件中，FBI花大量时间在那些一无所获的人身上是非常罕见的。如果他们花了好几个月，而他们所做的只是踢足球，FBI就会转移目标。如果克雷格在他们身上花了那么多时间，值得注意的是，很可能他们已经有了足以构成所谓“前提”（predicate）的依据，即调查他们的原因。你知道，比如截获了一个电话，或者FBI正在监视的某个人与海外有某种通信，这让FBI特工怀疑这个特定的小组。
In addition to Trevor, my producer and I talked to five longtime FBI agents, now retired, who all oversaw informants. They couldn't comment on Operation Flex specifically, and none of them knew first-hand about these Egyptian guys, but they gave us similar theories. Basically, they said if the FBI has even the smallest reason to suspect you, a reason you might not even be aware of yourself, they have to check you out.
除了特雷弗，我和我的制片人还与五位退休的长期FBI探员谈过，他们都曾管理过线人。他们不能具体评论“Flex”行动，而且他们中没有人第一手了解这些埃及人，但他们给了我们类似的理论。基本上，他们说如果FBI有哪怕最小的理由怀疑你，一个你自己甚至可能都没察觉到的理由，他们就必须调查你。
Maybe you happened to phone someone the FBI is monitoring. Maybe they got a bad tip. One of the ex-FBI agents said to me, "Do innocent people get investigated? Sure, every day. They can't weed them out without looking at them." Though one agent said it was possible that this was a case that just went awry, that was badly managed and didn't follow FBI protocols.
也许你碰巧给FBI正在监视的人打了电话。也许他们收到了错误的举报。其中一位前FBI特工对我说：“无辜的人会被调查吗？当然，每天都在发生。他们如果不去检查，就无法排除嫌疑。”不过，其中一位探员说，有可能这个案件只是走偏了，管理不善且没有遵循FBI的协议。
Months passed. People noticed that Craig was acting more devout. He began reciting prayers aloud, dressing in traditional robes, and showing up so early for 5:00 AM prayers that he'd get there before the person who unlocked the mosque every morning. They also noticed something else.
几个月过去了。人们注意到克雷格表现得越来越虔诚。他开始大声背诵祈祷词，穿着传统长袍，并早早地在凌晨5点到达礼拜，以至于他到得比每天早上为清真寺开门的人还要早。他们还注意到了另一件事。
Slowly and surely enough, during some times when we were having coffee, came the question of jihad.
慢慢地，肯定地，在我们喝咖啡的时候，出现了关于“圣战”（jihad）的问题。
Yassir, one of the Egyptians, had actually been asked questions about jihad before. Non-Muslims bring it up with them sometimes. Like, he'll be on a plane and the person next to him will ask about it. So he and his friends told Craig what they always tell people-- that jihad isn't what you see on the news. Jihad is really about each person's internal striving to be a good Muslim. It's not holy war. Here's Ayman.
埃及人之一的亚瑟，之前确实被问过关于圣战的问题。非穆斯林有时会和他们提起。比如，他在飞机上，旁边的人会问他。所以他和他的朋友们告诉克雷格他们一直告诉别人的——圣战并不是你在新闻上看到的那样。圣战实际上是关于每个人为了成为一名好穆斯林而进行的内心奋斗。不是圣战（Holy War）。这是艾曼的话。
The reality is, if I'm new to Islam, I would be very curious about this stuff too. I would be very curious about this stuff. That's what the media talks about all the time. So he must be very curious, you know.
事实是，如果我是伊斯兰教的新手，我也会对这些东西感到非常好奇。我会对这些东西非常好奇。那是媒体一直在谈论的事情。所以他一定很好奇，你知道。
I think there was a survey. If you mention Islam, the second thing you think about, in the American psyche, was "terrorist." So you know, for me it was somehow normal, if you look at it from a curiosity viewpoint. But it wasn't normal how obsessed he was with it, until we started being, you know, this guy is-- there is something very, very [BLEEP] up about this person. He just would bring these odd things in the middle of the conversation, out of nowhere.
我认为有一个调查。如果你提到伊斯兰教，在美国人的心理中，想到的第二件事就是“恐怖分子”。所以你知道，对我来说，如果你从好奇的角度来看，这在某种程度上是正常的。但他对此的痴迷程度并不正常，直到我们开始觉得，你知道，这家伙——这个人有什么非常、非常[脏话]问题。他总是会没来由地在谈话中间提起这些奇怪的事情。
For instance, the guys would be talking about food or sports.
例如，小伙子们在谈论食物或体育。
But yet, he would always bring politics into conversation. Ah, jihad, suicide bomber. So what do you want-- for example. I'm being sarcastic. What do you want to eat, Farouk? "So what do you think about Hosni Mubarak?" You know what I mean? Just out of nowhere.
但他总是会把政治带入谈话。啊，圣战，自杀式炸弹袭击者。所以你想——举个例子。我在讽刺。你想吃什么，法鲁克？“那你怎么看胡斯尼·穆巴拉克？”你懂我的意思吗？就这样毫无缘由地。
Craig talked to his Arabic teacher, Mohammad Elsisy, about his new obsession too.
克雷格也和他的阿拉伯语老师穆罕默德·埃尔西西（Mohammad Elsisy）谈论过他这种新的痴迷。
He invited me once to lunch, yes. And he focused the topic in the lunch about jihad. And I keep turning his attention into the essence of Islam. And he keeps, again, bringing it back to jihad. And he kept asking about jihad over and over and over. And I told him, Farouk, get over it, get over it, get over it.
他确实邀请我吃过一次午餐。他把午餐的话题聚焦在圣战上。我一直把他的注意力转回伊斯兰教的本质。但他又一直把它带回到圣战。他一遍又一遍地问关于圣战的问题。我告诉他，法鲁克，算了吧，算了吧，算了吧。
It alarmed all of them. At one point, Yassir confronted Farouk-- that is, Craig.
这让所有人都感到担忧。有一次，亚瑟与法鲁克——也就是克雷格——进行了对峙。
I even told him.  I'm like, Farouk, this needs to stop, because this is not the right direction. This is not what Islam's about. So if somebody's teaching you this, let me know, because we need to correct that immediately, right?
我甚至告诉了他。我说，法鲁克，这需要停止，因为这不是正确的方向。这不是伊斯兰教的意义。所以如果有人在教你这些，让我知道，因为我们需要立即纠正这一点，对吧？
And did he seem receptive?
他看起来听得进去吗？
He did. He did. And I told him, at this point, people are starting to wonder about what's going on, where you're learning this stuff from. So we need to kind of understand. And he was like, yeah, I'm not going to talk to anybody about this. I don't know. Maybe I was reading some incorrect stuff.
他听进去了。他确实听进去了。我告诉他，现在人们开始怀疑到底发生了什么，你在从哪里学这些东西。所以我们需要了解一下。他说，是的，我不会和任何人谈论这个。我不知道。也许我读了一些不正确的东西。
But Craig didn't listen. He didn't stop talking about jihad. He says this is what the FBI wanted, because, he says, he was great at it.
但克雷格没有听。他没有停止谈论圣战。他说这就是FBI想要的，因为，他说，他对此非常在行。
I would have to, in a very strategic way, get their views on jihad. And I got so good at it, in their view, that they wanted to enhance it. So I was to speak to, I think, 10 Muslims a day regarding jihad.
我必须以一种非常策略性的方式获取他们对圣战的看法。在他们看来，我做得非常好，以至于他们想加强它。所以我每天要和大约10个穆斯林谈论圣战。
Since the FBI isn't commenting, I ran this by Trevor Aaronson, the journalist who's examined about 500 counter-terrorism cases, to see if it was possible. He said that in all of those hundreds of cases, he's never heard of a quota like this. The ex-FBI agents I spoke with hadn't either. Though Trevor says that once a sting operation gets going, it's common for undercover agents and informants to bait suspects by asking them about jihad.
由于FBI不予置评，我向研究过约500起反恐案件的记者特雷弗·阿伦森核实了此事，看看这是否可能。他说，在那数百起案件中，他从未听说过这样的配额。我谈过的那些前FBI特工也没听说过。尽管特雷弗说，一旦卧底行动开始，卧底探员和线人通过询问嫌疑人关于圣战的问题来诱导他们是很常见的。
That happens in almost every undercover sting operation. I can tell you that in many of the cases I've looked at, that's mentioned in the criminal affidavit in some way. And I think when that's submitted at trial, that's a really damning piece of evidence for juries today.
那几乎发生在每一次卧底诱捕行动中。我可以告诉你，在我看过的许多案件中，刑事宣誓书中以某种方式提到了这一点。而且我认为当这在庭审中提交时，这对今天的陪审团来说是非常确凿的证据。
Craig took this strategy and ran with it. Mohammad, the Arabic teacher, heard complaints from his friends.
克雷格采取了这个策略并坚持了下去。阿拉伯语老师穆罕默德听到了来自他朋友们的抱怨。
It was to the limit that one of them told me, he keeps calling him by phone and keeps saying to him, "Jihad, jihad." I was like, you know, wait a minute.
到了那种地步，其中一个人告诉我，他一直打电话给他，并一直对他说：“圣战，圣战。”我当时想，你知道，等一下。
He would whisper "jihad" into the phone?
他会对着电话低声说“圣战”？
Yeah, into the phone.
是的，对着电话。
I asked Craig, did that happen?
我问克雷格，那是真的吗？
Probably. I'm not denying it. I may have been-- we had a conversation or something, and I had done something ridiculous like that. But I don't deny it. I'm sure I probably did, OK?
可能吧。我没有否认。我可能——我们有过谈话或者什么的，我做过那样荒谬的事情。但我并不否认。我敢肯定我可能确实做了，好吗？
What were you trying to accomplish with that?
你想通过那个达到什么目的？
Whatever individual heard that and they didn't quickly report me, they're automatically a suspect. Every single conversation is a conversation that the FBI or prosecutor can say, well, you heard him say this numerous times and yet you didn't do the following.
任何听到那个而没有立即举报我的人，他们自动就是嫌疑人。每一次谈话都是FBI或检察官可以说：好吧，你听过他多次这样说，但你却没有采取以下行动。
And so that's what you were trying to do?
所以这就是你试图做的？
Of course.
当然。
If you didn't think Craig could get any less subtle, here's another tactic he would try.
如果你不认为克雷格还能做得更不隐晦，这是他会尝试的另一个策略。
I'd say, let's meet tomorrow afternoon at the gym. We'll work out together. I'll teach you some things on how to get your forearms shaped a little better, your biceps stronger or bigger. And at these workouts, I would ask very sensitive questions regarding Islam. For example--
我会说，让我们明天下午在健身房见面。我们一起锻炼。我会教你一些如何让你的前臂形状更好，二头肌更强壮或更大的技巧。在这些锻炼中，我会问关于伊斯兰教的非常敏感的问题。例如——
So what do you think about Osama bin Laden?
那你怎么看奥萨马·本·拉登？
Ayman was working on his biceps when Craig asked him this.
当克雷格问艾曼这个问题时，艾曼正在锻炼他的二头肌。
I'm like, dude. OK. Osama bin Laden is a bad guy. He's a mother-[BLEEP]. You know what I mean? All that we are suffering from right now is because of Osama bin Laden. And your question right now is because of Osama bin Laden. You know what I mean? All of these new laws that they start acting about, just searching and sticking their finger in your butt, is because of Osama bin Laden. So you tell him, yeah, Osama bin Laden is the bad guy.
我说，老兄。好吧。奥萨马·本·拉登是个坏蛋。他是个妈的[脏话]。你懂我的意思吗？我们现在遭受的一切都是因为奥萨马·本·拉登。你现在问这个问题是因为奥萨马·本·拉登。你懂我的意思吗？所有这些他们开始实施的关于搜查、把手指伸进你屁股里的新法律，都是因为奥萨马·本·拉登。所以我告诉他，是的，奥萨马·本·拉登是个坏家伙。
One day, a guy named Riaz Surti showed up at the gym with a friend. Riaz had owned a halal KFC/Taco Bell nearby. Craig hopped off a stationary bike and introduced himself to Riaz as a fellow Muslim. Here's Riaz.
有一天，一个叫里亚兹·苏尔蒂（Riaz Surti）的家伙带了一个朋友出现在健身房。里亚兹在附近拥有一个清真KFC/Taco Bell。克雷格从固定自行车上跳下来，向里亚兹自我介绍为穆斯林伙伴。这是里亚兹。
Then I left to go stretch out, and then I came back. And then he leans to us, and then he says, I met the sheikh in Afghanistan.
然后我离开去拉伸，然后我回来了。然后他凑近我们说，我在阿富汗见过谢赫（sheikh）。
The sheikh?
谢赫？
The sheikh, yeah. I met the big guy or the sheikh in Afghanistan.
谢赫，是的。我在阿富汗见到了那个大人物或谢赫。
What did you think when he said that?
他这么说的时候你在想什么？
Oh, we knew that he was referring to Osama bin Laden. He was bragging. He was smiling that he met the sheikh. It just became very clear to us.
哦，我们知道他指的是奥萨马·本·拉登。他在吹嘘。他微笑着说他见过那个谢赫。这对我们来说变得非常清楚。
Craig told us he has never been to Afghanistan. But he was trying to see if these guys at the gym, who he'd never met, thought it would be cool to hang out with Osama bin Laden. They didn't think that would be cool. So instead, Riaz says, he wanted to get Craig to leave him alone. So every time he saw him, he would tell him the dirtiest jokes he could come up with.
克雷格告诉我们他从未去过阿富汗。但他试图看看在健身房这些他从未见过的人，是否觉得和奥萨马·本·拉登鬼混很酷。他们不觉得这很酷。所以相反，里亚兹说，他想让克雷格离他远点。所以每次见到他，他都会告诉他他能想到的最下流的笑话。
I didn't want him to think I was a good Muslim. I just felt like his goal was to get us involved in something that we weren't involved with.
我不想让他认为我是个好穆斯林。我只是觉得他的目标是让我们卷入我们没有参与的事情。
What did you tell him?
你告诉了他什么？
Like, did you hear about the doctor who was having sex with his patients? And he said no. And I said, he's a very interesting doctor. And then he looked at me. It was a veterinarian.
比如，你听说过那个和病人发生性关系的医生吗？他说没有。我说，他是一个非常有趣的医生。然后他看着我。那是位兽医。
It worked. Craig left him alone after that.
这奏效了。那之后克雷格没再缠着他。
About eight months into Operation Flex, Craig says his handlers told him to start talking to people about an actual terrorist plot, a plan to blow up buildings in Southern California. That happens in lots of FBI stings. The informant suggests the plot to the suspect, not the other way around, according to Trevor Aaronson again, who studied hundreds of terrorism convictions.
“Flex”行动进行到大约八个月时，克雷格说他的处理员告诉他开始和人们谈论一个实际的恐怖主义阴谋，一个炸毁南加州建筑的计划。这在很多FBI诱捕行动中都会发生。根据特雷弗·阿伦森的研究，线人向嫌疑人建议阴谋，而不是反过来。
Of about 500 terrorism cases since 9/11, about 50 defendants have been involved in cases where the informant came up with the idea and provided all of the means.
自9/11以来的约500起恐怖主义案件中，约有50名被告涉及的案件中，是线人提出了想法并提供了所有手段。
But ex-FBI agents I talked to said that in a well-run operation, the informant is not supposed to suggest the plot out of the blue. First, the suspect would have to declare his intention to commit an act of violence. Without that, the whole case could get thrown out of court as entrapment.
但我谈过的FBI前特工说，在管理良好的行动中，线人不应该突然提出阴谋。首先，嫌疑人必须声明其犯下暴力行为的意图。没有这一点，整个案件都可能因“诱导犯罪”（entrapment）而在法庭上被驳回。
The person Craig suggested his plot to was a guy named Ahmad Niazi Niazi is the only person we know of that Craig helped catch, the only person the FBI arrested as a result of Operation Flex. Craig had met Niazi one night at the Irvine mosque. Mohammad, Craig's Arabic teacher, introduced them.
克雷格建议阴谋的对象是一个叫艾哈迈德·尼亚兹（Ahmad Niazi）的人。尼亚兹是我们知道的克雷格帮助抓获的唯一一个人，也是FBI因“Flex”行动逮捕的唯一一个人。克雷格是在尔湾清真寺的一个晚上见到尼亚兹的。克雷格的阿拉伯语老师穆罕默德介绍了他们认识。
Niazi was a family man, very different from the Egyptian Xbox players. He had a wife and two young kids and taught at a nearby language school. Niazi grew up in Afghanistan, but he'd lived in California for eight years. He and Craig went out for coffee, and they hit it off. They started hanging out a lot, sometimes with Mohammad.
尼亚兹是个顾家的人，与那些埃及Xbox玩家非常不同。他有一个妻子和两个年幼的孩子，在附近的一所语言学校教书。尼亚兹在阿富汗长大，但在加利福尼亚住了八年。他和克雷格出去喝咖啡，他们很合得来。他们开始经常聚在一起，有时和穆罕默德一起。
One Friday, the three of them were driving to a mosque where Mohammad was scheduled to give a sermon. Niazi didn't want to do an interview for our story, but here's Mohammad.
一个周五，他们三个人开车去一家清真寺，穆罕默德原定在那里布道。尼亚兹不想接受我们的采访，但这是穆罕默德的话。
Niazi was sitting in the backseat and Farouk was sitting in the passenger, and I was driving.
尼亚兹坐在后座，法鲁克坐在副驾驶座，我在开车。
And here's Craig, AKA Farouk.
这是克雷格，也就是法鲁克。
And I started to bring up, what should we really do as Muslims now that our brothers and sisters are being blown up in Afghanistan and Iraq?
我开始提起，既然我们的兄弟姐妹在阿富汗和伊拉克被炸死，我们作为穆斯林现在到底该做什么？
And I told him, Farouk, we are living in Irvine, the most peaceful city in all America. [LAUGHS] He was like, I just don't like the way that American government is handing situations outside and stuff. And I was like, OK, and what?
我告诉他，法鲁克，我们住在尔湾，全美国最和平的城市。[笑] 他说，我只是不喜欢美国政府处理外部局势的方式之类的。我说，好的，然后呢？
Are we supposed to just stay here, watch our national championship games, play Xbox, and everything else, while our brothers are being killed?
我们难道就该待在这里，看我们的全国冠军赛，玩Xbox，做别的事情，而我们的兄弟却在被杀害？
And he started talking about some jihad.
然后他开始谈论一些关于圣战的事情。
I mean, I became very aggressive.
我的意思是我变得非常有攻击性。
And I told him, Farouk, what are you trying to get into, exactly?
我告诉他，法鲁克，你到底想介入什么？
I said, we should carry out a terrorist attack in this country, because I'm tired of just staying around doing nothing. I've got access to weapons. I know how to do things. We should bomb something.
我说，我们应该在这个国家发动一次恐怖袭击，因为我厌倦了无所事事地待着。我有武器来源。我知道怎么做。我们应该炸点什么。
Silence was out there in the car. I didn't say a word until we arrived to the mosque. I refused to talk at all. The first thing that came into my mind, I thought that he's a straight-shot terrorist. And at that point, I felt kind of scared from him. He scared me.
车里一片寂静。直到我们到达清真寺我都没说一句话。我拒绝说任何话。我脑子里想的第一件事就是，我觉得他是一个彻头彻尾的恐怖分子。在那个时候，我对他感到有点害怕。他吓到我了。
Mohammad glanced into the rearview mirror and saw Niazi staring back at him. He looked shocked. Craig's head was down. He was now playing with his phone. No one said anything for the remaining 20 minutes of the ride to the mosque. The drive back home was the same.
穆罕默德扫了一眼后视镜，看到尼亚兹正盯着他。他看起来很震惊。克雷格低着头。他现在在玩手机。在去清真寺剩余的20分钟车程里，没人说话。回家的路也是一样。
After they parted ways with Craig, Mohammad and Niazi talked about what had just happened. They decided they had to do something, so they did what all Americans are supposed to do in this situation, what law enforcement officials tell us we should do when someone says he has access to weapons and wants to use them. They reported Craig to the FBI as a potential terrorist.
在与克雷格分开后，穆罕默德和尼亚兹谈论了刚刚发生的事情。他们决定必须采取行动，所以他们做了所有美国人在这种情况下应该做的事，执法官员告诉我们当某人说他有武器并想使用它们时我们应该做的事。他们向FBI举报了克雷格，称其为潜在恐怖分子。
Coming up, what happens, exactly, when you turn in someone to the FBI who is working for the FBI? Sam Black's story continues in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，当你向FBI举报一个实际上为FBI工作的人时，到底会发生什么？萨姆·布莱克的报道将在片刻后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- "The Convert," the story of an FBI undercover operation from 2006 that went very badly, is, I think, a fair way to say it, and the uneasy relationship between some Muslims and the FBI, and why that might be. And as I said at the top of the show, this is not a typical FBI investigation, the story we're telling today.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——“皈依者”，讲述了2006年一次非常糟糕的FBI卧底行动，我觉得这是一个公平的说法，以及一些穆斯林与FBI之间不安的关系，以及为什么会这样。正如我在节目开头所说的，我们今天讲述的这个故事并非典型的FBI调查。
It's hard to say exactly what constitutes failure if you're a government informant, but I think that being turned over to authorities as a possible terrorist yourself by the people you suspect are terrorists-- that's got to be on the list, right? That's not good. Sam Black picks up our story where we left off.
如果你是一名政府线人，很难确切地说什么是失败，但我认为被你怀疑是恐怖分子的人作为可能的恐怖分子交给当局——这肯定在名单上，对吧？那可不好。萨姆·布莱克从我们刚才中断的地方继续讲述我们的故事。
So Mohammad and Niazi wanted to report Craig to the FBI, but they weren't sure who to call or how to do it. They reached out to Hussam Ayloush. Hussam is director of the Council on American Islamic Relations in Southern California, known as CAIR, along with the ACLU, and a well-known member of the Muslim community there. Just hours after the car ride, he got a phone call from Mohammad. Here's Hussam.
所以穆罕默德和尼亚兹想向FBI举报克雷格，但他们不确定打给谁或怎么做。他们联系了胡萨姆·阿尤什（Hussam Ayloush）。胡萨姆是南加州美国伊斯兰关系委员会（CAIR）的负责人，与美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）一起，是当地穆斯林社区的一位知名成员。车程发生几小时后，他接到了穆罕默德的电话。这是胡萨姆。
He was terrified. The guy didn't know what to do. He was so nervous. He told me, I know you deal with the FBI and I know you work with police. What do I do now?
他被吓坏了。这家伙不知道该怎么办。他非常紧张。他告诉我，我知道你和FBI打交道，也知道你和警察合作。我现在该怎么办？
Mohammad was with Niazi. They were both afraid that if Craig went ahead with his plot, they would somehow be responsible.
穆罕默德当时和尼亚兹在一起。他们都很害怕，如果克雷格真的实施了他的阴谋，他们会以某种方式承担责任。
He passed the phone to Niazi, and he was also panicking like crazy. I mean, both of them, they didn't know what to do. I told them, don't worry about it. Calm down. You're not responsible for anything. You're doing the right thing. You're calling the authorities. So even if the guy is planning on anything, you have nothing to worry about. You're not accomplices.
他把电话递给尼亚兹，他也像疯了一样恐慌。我的意思是，他们俩都不知道该怎么办。我告诉他们，别担心。冷静下来。你们不对任何事情负责。你们在做正确的事。你们在联系当局。所以即使那个人在策划什么，你们也无需担心。你们不是同谋。
So what did you think was going on when you got this call?
当你接到这个电话时，你认为发生了什么？
There were three possibilities. Either he is recruited by al-Qaeda, or he's a lone wolf doing things on his own, or he's doing this for somebody else as an entrapment. Either way, it's bad news.
有三种可能。要么他被基地组织招募了，要么他是个独自行动的“孤狼”，要么他是在为别人做诱导犯罪。无论哪种方式，这都不是好消息。
Hussam told Muhammad and Niazi that he would call the FBI. For years, he'd been attending monthly meetings with agents who hoped to build a good relationship with the Muslim community. And he was friends with Steve Tidwell, the head of the FBI's LA office.
胡萨姆告诉穆罕默德和尼亚兹，他会打给FBI。多年来，他一直参加与特工的月度会议，他们希望与穆斯林社区建立良好的关系。而且他和FBI洛杉矶办公室负责人史蒂夫·蒂德韦尔是朋友。
Hussam had actually organized the outreach meeting you heard about earlier, the one where Tidwell promised that the FBI wouldn't send people into mosques unannounced. So Hussam called Tidwell on his cell phone and told him what had happened to Mohammad and Niazi. They thought this guy in the car might be serious. Again, here's Hussam.
胡萨姆实际上组织了你们之前听到的那次外联会议，蒂德韦尔承诺FBI不会派人未经宣布进入清真寺。所以胡萨姆用手机打给了蒂德韦尔，告诉了他穆罕默德和尼亚兹身上发生的事情。他们认为车里的这个人可能是认真的。这是胡萨姆的声音。
He said, well, you know, thanks, Hussam. You're doing the right thing. Thank these gentleman. This is exactly why we're so proud of working with the Muslim community.
他说，好吧，你知道，谢谢，胡萨姆。你做了正确的事。感谢这些绅士。这正是我们为能与穆斯林社区合作感到自豪的原因。
And I did mention it. I said, he's a white guy, a white convert in Irvine. He said, oh. That's what he said. Oh, OK. Thank you, Hussam. That-- that's great information. And we'll-- we'll let you know what happens.
我也提到了这一点。我说，他是个白人，尔湾的一个白人皈依者。他说，哦。他就是这么说的。哦，好的。谢谢，胡萨姆。那——那真是很好的信息。我们会——我们会让你知道发生了什么。
I said, wait, wait. Don't you need his name? Because I had his name and I had his address, because they knew where he lived.
我说，等等，等等。你不需要他的名字吗？因为我有他的名字，我也有他的地址，因为他们知道他住在哪里。
He said, well, you know, don't worry about it. We work closely with Irvine PD, and we'll take care of it from here. Don't worry about it. That's when my doubts started playing in my head. I felt there was something strange.
他说，好吧，你知道，别担心。我们与尔湾警察局密切合作，剩下的我们会处理。别担心。就在那时，我的疑虑开始在脑海中闪现。我觉得有些奇怪。
Tidwell wouldn't speak to me for this story, so I don't know what he thought when his own informant was reported to him as a terrorist. But not long after this phone call, the FBI launched an investigation into Craig, which no matter how you look at it was a very strange undertaking. FBI agents were going around asking questions about an FBI informant, treating him as an actual suspect they were investigating.
蒂德韦尔没有就这个故事与我交谈，所以我不知道当他自己的线人被举报为恐怖分子时他在想什么。但在这次通话后不久，FBI对克雷格展开了调查，无论你怎么看，这都是一项非常奇怪的工作。FBI特工到处打听一个FBI线人的情况，把他当作一个他们正在调查的实际嫌疑人对待。
FBI special agents not only interviewed Mohammad and Niazi, they also questioned other people who'd been hanging out with Craig. I talked to five people who willingly took part in these interviews. At the time, they thought they were helping catch a dangerous person. Mohammad and Niazi even went in front of a judge in Orange County Superior Court and got a restraining order against Craig so that he couldn't come within 200 yards of the mosque.
FBI特工不仅采访了穆罕默德和尼亚兹，还询问了其他曾与克雷格一起混的人。我采访了五位自愿参加这些采访的人。当时，他们认为自己在帮助抓捕一个危险的人。穆罕默德和尼亚兹甚至来到奥兰治县高等法院的法官面前，对克雷格申请了禁制令，让他不能靠近清真寺200码范围内。
But looking back, the people the FBI interviewed told me there was something weird about the way the agents were acting through this whole ordeal. They just didn't seem that concerned. Yassir, one of the Egyptians, said it wasn't what he imagined would happen when you call in the feds on a possible terrorist.
但回想起来，那些接受FBI采访的人告诉我，在这整个磨难过程中，特工们的行为方式有些怪异。他们似乎并没有那么关心。埃及人之一的亚瑟说，这和他想象中举报一个可能的恐怖分子时会发生的情况不一样。
My picture in my head is, if you go and bring that up, it's on. Let's go. Let's find this person. Let's make sure we're stopping him. They would be at his door immediately. 30 cars, movie-style, kind of like, break in, let's get this guy. That wasn't the reaction. That wasn't the reaction we were getting.
我脑子里的画面是，如果你去提出这一点，那就会立刻行动。我们出发吧。我们要找到这个人。我们要确保阻止他。他们会立刻出现在他门口。30辆车，电影般的风格，有点像是，破门而入，抓住这家伙。那不是这种反应。那不是我们得到的反应。
The agents did ask questions about Craig. How often did he come to the mosque? Who else did he hang out with? What kinds of things did he say?
特工们确实问了关于克雷格的问题。他多久来一次清真寺？他还和谁一起混？他说了些什么样的话？
But with Yassir and others, they gradually began to ask more personal questions. How many times did you talk with Farouk about jihad? What do you think jihad means? When did you come to the United States? Again, Yassir.
但对于亚瑟和其他人，他们逐渐开始问更个人的问题。你和法鲁克谈过多少次圣战？你认为圣战是什么意思？你什么时候来到美国的？再次是亚瑟的声音。
These guys knew exactly what was going on. They knew he was their informant. I think it was just another way for them to kind of get us in and talk to them.
这些家伙完全知道发生了什么。他们知道他是他们的线人。我认为这只是他们让我们进去和他们谈话的另一种方式。
Some people were visited by the FBI more than once, like Mohammad. One day, FBI agents surprised him at his house. He asked them how the investigation into Farouk was going. They told him Farouk was a dangerous guy and he would be in trouble soon. But Mohammad says the agents were there to talk about someone else.
有些人不止一次受到FBI的拜访，比如穆罕默德。有一天，FBI特工在他家给了他一个“惊喜”。他问他们对法鲁克的调查进展如何。他们告诉他法鲁克是个危险的人，很快就会有麻烦了。但穆罕默德说，特工们在那儿是想谈论另一个人。
They asked me a couple of questions about Ahmad Niazi, how much information I know about him. And I told them, I don't know anything about Ahmad Niazi, except that he is a person that comes and prays in the mosque, and I know him through the community. I didn't know him before that, and I don't know very much information about him.
他们问了我几个关于艾哈迈德·尼亚兹的问题，我对他了解多少信息。我告诉他们，我对艾哈迈德·尼亚兹一无所知，只知道他是一个来清真寺祈祷的人，我通过社区认识他。在那之前我不认识他，关于他我没有太多信息。
They said, you know, we just wanted to collect more information about that person. I told them, I told you what I know about him. That's all.
他们说，你知道，我们只是想收集关于那个人的更多信息。我告诉他们，我告诉过你们我知道关于他的事情了。就这些。
This was strange for Mohammad. Niazi was the one who'd help him report Craig. Why were the FBI agents asking about him?
这对穆罕默德来说很奇怪。尼亚兹是帮助他举报克雷格的人。为什么FBI探员要问关于他的事情？
By the spring of 2007, the FBI had honed in on Niazi. It's unclear exactly why, but court records reveal one thing that got their attention. One of Niazi's sisters was married to a man named Amin al-Haq. Al-Haq was designated as a terrorist by the US government. He'd allegedly served as a security coordinator for Osama bin Laden.
到了2007年春天，FBI已经锁定了尼亚兹。尚不清楚具体原因，但法庭记录揭示了一件引起他们注意的事。尼亚兹的一个姐妹嫁给了一个叫阿明·哈克（Amin al-Haq）的人。哈克被美国政府定为恐怖分子。据称，他曾担任奥萨马·本·拉登的安全协调员。
And Niazi also said things to Craig that concerned the FBI. None of Craig's recordings have been released, so we don't know what exactly they talked about. But Craig gave us dozens of emails Niazi sent him.
而且尼亚兹也对克雷格说了些让FBI担忧的话。克雷格的录音都没有公布，所以我们不知道他们到底谈了什么。但克雷格给了我们尼亚兹发给他的几十封电子邮件。
They're mostly articles and links to videos. Some of these are conspiracy theories, like how 9/11 was an inside job. Others criticized the wars in Afghanistan and Iraq, sometimes calling for Muslims to rise up against their enemies. This YouTube video is the most extreme thing my producer and I found in the emails. It's an imam talking about how he supports Osama bin Laden.
大部分是文章和视频链接。其中一些是阴谋论，比如9/11是如何从内部策划的。另一些则批评在阿富汗和伊拉克的战争，有时呼吁穆斯林奋起反抗他们的敌人。这个YouTube视频是我和我的制片人在邮件中发现的最极端的东西。这是一个伊玛目在谈论他如何支持奥萨马·本·拉登。
If he's terrorizing the terrorists, if he's terrorizing America the terrorist, biggest terrorist, I am with him. Every Muslim should be a terrorist. The thing is that, if he's terrorizing a terrorist, he's for Islam.
如果他在恐吓恐怖分子，如果他在恐吓美国这个恐怖分子，最大的恐怖分子，我与他同在。每个穆斯林都应该成为恐怖分子。重点是，如果他在恐吓恐怖分子，他就是为了伊斯兰教。
In case you didn't get that, he said, "Every Muslim should be a terrorist." Niazi sent this video to an undercover FBI informant-- Craig.
如果你没听明白，他说，“每个穆斯林都应该成为恐怖分子。”尼亚兹把这个视频发给了一个卧底FBI线人——克雷格。
They said that I hit a jackpot with Niazi. They called it a jackpot.
他们说我在尼亚兹身上中了大奖。他们称之为中大奖。
Even after Niazi turned Craig in, for nearly a year, the FBI continued to surveil Niazi. Finally, two agents came to talk to him. After they left, Niazi immediately called Hussam Ayloush at CAIR.
即使在尼亚兹把克雷格举报之后，FBI也继续监视尼亚兹近一年。最后，两名特工来找他谈话。他们离开后，尼亚兹立即打电话给CAIR的胡萨姆·阿尤什。
He actually was crying. I mean, he was crying like a little kid, very fearful, and he kept repeating, I'm the one who called the FBI. I'm the one, and now they're turning on me?
他当时其实在哭。我的意思是，他像个小孩子一样在哭，非常恐惧，他一直重复说，我才是那个打电话给FBI的人。我是那个人，现在他们却在针对我？
The lead agent who met with Niazi was Thomas Ropel, who handled his case inside the FBI. Niazi said Ropel threatened him, told him that the FBI had something on him, told Niazi that he'd lied to them-- which is a federal crime-- at an earlier meeting with FBI agents, one of the meetings where Niazi thought he was there to help the FBI catch Craig. Here's Hussam. Some
负责会见尼亚兹的首席特工是托马斯·罗佩尔（Thomas Ropel），他在FBI内部负责他的案件。尼亚兹说罗佩尔威胁他，告诉他FBI掌握了他的把柄，告诉尼亚兹他在早些时候与FBI特工的一次会面中撒了谎——那是一项联邦罪行——那是尼亚兹以为他是去帮助FBI抓捕克雷格的会议之一。这是胡萨姆。
And the agent actually told him, based on our interviews with you, you have made comments that are not accurate, and this would be perjury. And I feel bad for you, but you know, it's in your hand. You can change all that if you cooperate with us. They said, you speak Arabic, Pashto, and Dari, and you could be a great asset in helping us protect the country.
探员其实告诉他，根据我们对你的采访，你发表了不准确的评论，这可能构成伪证罪。我为你感到遗憾，但你知道，这取决于你自己。如果你与我们合作，你可以改变这一切。他们说，你会说阿拉伯语、普什图语和达里语，你可以成为帮助我们保护国家的宝贵资产。
He said, well, that's what I did. I don't need to work for you. When I saw something bad, I'm the one who picked up the phone and reported it. Well, we need you here and we need you in Afghanistan. They offered him to be in Afghanistan. And they offered him money.
他说，好吧，这就是我所做的。我不需要为你工作。当我看到坏事时，是我拿起电话举报它的。好吧，我们需要你在这里，我们需要你在阿富汗。他们提议让他去阿富汗。而且他们还给了钱。
He said, I'm not going to go and spy on my people. I told you.  If I see something bad, I'll report it. And then the guy told him, I hope you think about it, because if you don't, we can make your life a living hell.
他说，我不会去监视我的人民。我告诉过你。如果我看到坏事，我会举报。然后那家伙告诉他，我希望你好好考虑一下，因为如果你不这样做，我们可以让你生不如死。
That's what they said to him?
他们真的是那样对他说的？
That's exactly the quote he gave me, because I wrote it down as he was talking to me.
那就是他给我的原话，因为他在和我说话时我把它写下来了。
Thomas Ropel confirmed in court that this meeting happened, though he did not say that he pressured Niazi to work for the FBI. But ex-FBI agents my producer and I talked to said it's common to leverage people like this. Again, they weren't commenting on Niazi's case, but one retired agent who had more than 20 years experience in the Bureau said there are people all over the country being approached by the FBI and pressured with things they said on tapes.
托马斯·罗佩尔在法庭上证实了这次会面确实发生过，尽管他没有说他曾向尼亚兹施压要他为FBI工作。但我与我的制片人交谈过的FBI前特工说，利用这种方式给人们施压是很常见的。同样，他们没有评论尼亚兹的案件，但一位在FBI工作过20多年、经验丰富的退休特工说，全国各地到处都有人被FBI接触，并被他们录音带里的言论所要挟。
He laughed when we asked him about it. It was like asking a plumber if he used a wrench. He says it happens at every level of law enforcement.
当我们问他这件事时，他笑了。就像问一个水管工是否使用扳手一样。他说这种情况发生在执法的各个层面。
He told us, quote, "it sounds like a terrible thing, guys, but it's the way business is done. It's the way the American people get protected. You've got to find people who can lead you to the bad guys."
他告诉我们，引用的话说，“这听起来是一件可怕的事情，伙计们，但这确实是业务开展的方式。这是美国人民得到保护的方式。你必须找到能引导你找到坏人的人。”
Thomas Ropel returned with a group of agents and a search warrant. They raided Niazi's house, taking computers and financial documents. Months later, Ropel returned again and arrested Niazi.
托马斯·罗佩尔带着一群特工和搜查令回来了。他们突袭了尼亚兹的房子，拿走了电脑和财务文件。几个月后，罗佩尔再次回来并逮捕了尼亚兹。
For the second time, federal authorities move in on this Tustin home. Their target? The 34-year-old owner.
联邦当局第二次进入这个塔斯廷（Tustin）的家。他们的目标？这位34岁的屋主。
Tonight this local home looks empty, but today it was the scene of an FBI raid. The suspect? A man with alleged ties to terrorists.
今晚这个当地的家看起来空荡荡的，但今天它是FBI突袭的现场。嫌疑人？一个与恐怖分子有涉嫌联系的人。
The government charged Niazi with immigration fraud and making false statements. They said that when Niazi applied for US citizenship, he didn't mention that his sister was married to Amin al-Haq, even though you're required to disclose if you have any ties to a designated terrorist. They also charged him for using inconsistent versions of his full name on official forms and for not disclosing two trips he'd made to Pakistan years earlier.
政府指控尼亚兹犯有移民欺诈罪和作虚假陈述罪。他们说，当尼亚兹申请美国公民身份时，他没有提到他的姐妹嫁给了阿明·哈克，尽管如果你有任何与指定恐怖分子的联系，法律要求必须披露。他们还指控他在官方表格上使用全名的不一致版本，以及没有披露他多年前两次前往巴基斯坦的行程。
But what's interesting about Niazi's arrest is what he wasn't charged with. He wasn't charged with associating with terrorists himself. He wasn't charged with plotting an attack. And he wasn't charged for anything he'd ever said to Craig over the course of months of recorded conversations. Still, at Niazi's bail hearing, the prosecutor argued that he was a danger to the community. To prove that, she called Agent Thomas Ropel to the stand.
但尼亚兹被捕的有趣之处在于他没有被指控什么。他没有被指控与恐怖分子本身有联系。他没有被指控策划袭击。而且他没有因在长达数月的录音对话中对克雷格说过任何话而被指控。尽管如此，在尼亚兹的保释听证会上，检察官争辩说他是社区的威胁。为了证明这一点，她传唤特工托马斯·罗佩尔出庭作证。
Will you please state your full name for the record?
请为了记录说出你的全名？
Special Agent Thomas J. Ropel III.
特别探员托马斯·J·罗佩尔三世。
How do you spell your last name, please?
请问你的姓怎么拼？
R-O-P-E-L.
R-O-P-E-L。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Ropel testified that a confidential informant had recorded Niazi talking about jihad between 15 and 20 times. In addition, he said--
罗佩尔作证说，一名机密线人记录了尼亚兹在15到20次之间谈论圣战。此外，他说——
There were some recordings that I had personally listened to regarding Mr. Niazi discussing gaining access to weapons and discussing blowing up buildings. And--
我个人听过一些关于尼亚兹先生讨论获取武器和讨论炸毁建筑的录音。而且——
As Ropel went on, the judge asked him to clarify who had brought up these conversations-- Niazi or the informant?
当罗佩尔继续说时，法官要求他澄清是谁发起了这些对话——尼亚兹还是线人？
Mr. Niazi has instigated these conversations with that individual.
尼亚兹先生与那个人发起了这些对话。
He instigated the conversation?
他发起了对话？
Mr. Niazi did, yes. Correct.
是的，尼亚兹先生确实发起了。没错。
Of course, the individual he supposedly instigated conversations with was Craig Monteilh. I asked Craig about it.
当然，他所谓的发起对话的对象是克雷格·蒙泰尔。我问过克雷格这件事。
Did Niazi ever instigate this kind of conversation with you?
尼亚兹真的有发起过这种对话吗？
No. No, I did. Every time.
没有。没有，是我。每一次。
Craig has changed his story on this. When Niazi was arrested in 2009, he basically said the complete opposite. He said Niazi recruited him for a terrorist operation. But Craig says now he's telling the truth. He says what really happened is that he went after Niazi more aggressively than anyone. Niazi wanted a friend, and he tolerated Craig's jihad talk more than most.
克雷格在这个问题上改变了说法。2009年尼亚兹被捕时，他基本上说了完全相反的话。他说尼亚兹招募他进行恐怖主义行动。但克雷格说他现在在说实话。他说真正发生的是，他比任何人都更积极地去针对尼亚兹。尼亚兹想要一个朋友，而且他比大多数人更能容忍克雷格的圣战谈话。
The thing about Niazi was he'd try to impress me. He's, like, 5'5" or so, and I was somewhat intimidating to him. So he kind of just went along with what I said. He didn't say he wanted to be a part of this. But he didn't say to me, no, I don't. That's a very bad thing to do when you're being recorded.
关于尼亚兹的事情是，他试图给我留下深刻印象。他身高大约5英尺5英寸，而我在某种程度上对他有威慑力。所以他基本上只是顺着我说的做。他没说他想参与其中。但他也没对我说是，我不。当你被录音时，这是一种非常糟糕的做法。
Did you feel like, I've got this guy who's ideologically leaning towards jihad?
你当时感觉是，我抓住了这个在意识形态上倾向于圣战的家伙吗？
What I thought was, I can bring him there. He was afraid. He looked like he was scared, which is where I wanted him to be. And my handlers told me to reel him in more. And he was just kind of mesmerized by me.
我当时想的是，我可以把他带到那一步。他很害怕。他看起来很害怕，这正是我想让他处于的状态。而我的处理员告诉我再多把他拉拢进来一点。他只是被我迷住了。
I talked to people who know Niazi, and they backed this up. Niazi mentored Craig, but at the same time he was enthralled by him, at least until the moment when he and Mohammad decided to turn Craig in to the FBI.
我采访了认识尼亚兹的人，他们也证实了这一点。尼亚兹指导了克雷格，但与此同时他也被他迷住了，至少直到他和穆罕默德决定把克雷格举报给FBI的那一刻。
The government kept Niazi under house arrest for more than a year, with a curfew and an ankle bracelet. When I reached out to Niazi for this story, he sent me a statement. It says in part, "When the FBI agent threatened to make my life a living hell unless I became an informant, which I refused, the FBI made true its promise and really did make my life a living hell. In the past few years, my family and I have been struggling very hard to piece back together our lives."
政府将尼亚兹软禁了超过一年，实施宵禁并带上脚镣。当我为了这个故事联系尼亚兹时，他发给我一份声明。声明部分写道：“当FBI特工威胁说除非我成为线人否则就让我生不如死，但我拒绝了，FBI兑现了它的承诺，真的让我的生活生不如死。过去几年，我和家人一直在非常艰难地试图重建我们的生活。”
The government eventually decided it didn't want to pursue Niazi's case. It filed a motion to dismiss all of the charges. Operation Flex ended without a single known conviction.
政府最终决定不追究尼亚兹的案件。它提交了一份驳回所有指控的动议。“Flex”行动在没有任何已知定罪的情况下结束了。
One person did go to jail, though-- Craig Monteilh. Six months after Craig was reported as a potential terrorist, the Irvine police arrested him for a bizarre unrelated crime. It turned out that during Operation Flex, he'd been running a side hustle, conning two women out of more than $150,000 in a scheme to traffic human growth hormone. He met the women at the same gyms where he was monitoring Muslims. He went to prison for eight months.
不过，确实有一个人入狱了——克雷格·蒙泰尔。在克雷格被举报为潜在恐怖分子六个月后，尔湾警察局因一起古怪且不相关的犯罪逮捕了他。事实证明，在“Flex”行动期间，他一直在搞副业，在一个贩卖人类生长激素的计划中，骗了两个女人超过15万美元。他在监视穆斯林的健身房里遇到了这些女人。他入狱服刑八个月。
Craig sued the FBI over this, claiming the whole thing was part of an FBI drug sting and that his handlers conspired to have him arrested after he became useless in Operation Flex. A judge recently threw the case out.
克雷格就此事起诉了FBI，声称整件事是FBI毒品诱捕行动的一部分，他的处理员在他失去“Flex”行动的价值后密谋逮捕他。法官最近驳回了此案。
You can probably imagine what Operation Flex and its aftermath did to relations between the FBI and the Muslim community in Orange County. Hussam Ayloush, the head of CAIR in Southern California, remembers the moment at Niazi's bail hearing when the FBI revealed that Craig was an undercover informant. Hussam was in the courtroom.
你大概能想象“Flex”行动及其余波对FBI与奥兰治县穆斯林社区之间关系的影响。南加州CAIR负责人胡萨姆·阿尤什记得，在尼亚兹的保释听证会上，当FBI透露克雷格是卧底线人时那一刻的情景。胡萨姆当时就在法庭上。
It's almost like a dagger in my back. I felt betrayed. The whole community, not just me.
那简直就像背后捅了一刀。我感到被背叛了。整个社区，不仅仅是我。
We felt betrayed, because we talk about a partnership. If you see something, report it. If you suspect criminal behavior, call the police.
我们感到被背叛了，因为我们谈论的是伙伴关系。如果你看到什么，就举报。如果你怀疑有犯罪行为，就打电话报警。
People were saying, why should we do it? We're going to be the target of the investigation. The reality is, they never thought of us as partners. For them, we were always suspects. We were always deemed as suspects or potential terrorists.
人们当时在说，我们为什么要这样做？我们会被作为调查的对象。事实是，他们从未把我们当作伙伴。对他们来说，我们永远是嫌疑人。我们一直被视为嫌疑人或潜在恐怖分子。
Operation Flex didn't just make people suspicious of law enforcement. It made them suspicious of each other. So many people I talked to say they stay away from new converts now. They have a hard time believing people are who they say they are. Here's Ayman, the Egyptian guy who first befriended Craig.
“Flex”行动不仅让人怀疑执法部门，还让人怀疑彼此。我谈过的这么多人说他们现在远离新皈依者。他们很难相信人们就是他们说的那样。这是艾曼的话，最初结交克雷格的那个埃及人。
Really, what they did is they made everybody in the mosque not trust everybody. Nobody would talk about it, but nobody-- you would see some weird looks, you know what I mean? People are looking at each other weird. I don't know. Maybe I was sensitive, but I can tell that the way they looked at me was just different.
真的，他们所做的是让清真寺里的每个人都不信任每个人。没人会谈论它，但没人——你会看到一些奇怪的目光，你懂我的意思吗？人们互相看着对方都很奇怪。我不知道。也许我很敏感，但我能看出他们看我的方式完全不同。
In one of the most awkward developments of this story, the Muslim community is now teaming up with Craig Monteilh. The Council on American Islamic Relations, CAIR, is suing the FBI over Operation Flex. The government is arguing in response that allowing the case to go forward would reveal state secrets and harm national security.
在这个故事最尴尬的发展之一中，穆斯林社区现在正与克雷格·蒙泰尔联手。美国伊斯兰关系委员会（CAIR）正在就“Flex”行动起诉FBI。作为回应，政府争辩说，让此案继续进行会泄露国家机密并损害国家安全。
Craig is CAIR's primary resource in the case. He's now helping the people he used to spy on. And he's been apologizing to some of them, too. He sees them often because he still lives around the corner from the Irvine mosque and works out in the same gym. He made a special point of calling Yassir Abdel Rahim, one of the first people he got close to.
克雷格是该案中CAIR的主要资源。他现在正在帮助那些他曾经监视过的人。而且他也一直在向他们中的一些人道歉。他经常见到他们，因为他仍然住在离尔湾清真寺转角处的地方，并且在同一个健身房锻炼。他特地给亚瑟·阿卜杜勒·拉希姆打了电话，这是他曾经接近过的第一批人之一。
Um-- [SIGHS HEAVILY] you know, I definitely appreciate the fact that he called and that he apologized for it, but the damage is done. I don't know what to do. I really don't. I now have a fear that I'm being monitored all the time. I don't know how you can change that.
呃—— [沉重地叹气] 你知道，我绝对感谢他打电话并为此道歉的事实，但伤害已经造成了。我不知道该怎么办。我真的不知道。我现在有一种害怕被一直监视的恐惧。我不知道你该怎么改变这一点。
Craig's not the only one apologizing. After Niazi's charges were dismissed, he went to the courthouse to retrieve some of the property that the FBI had seized from his house. Thomas Ropel was there. They talked for about 20 minutes.
道歉的不仅仅是克雷格。在尼亚兹的指控被撤销后，他去法院取回FBI从他家中查扣的一些财产。托马斯·罗佩尔也在那里。他们谈了大约20分钟。
Remember, Ropel is the agent who allegedly threatened Niazi, who later arrested him, and who then testified in court that he was a danger to society. I spoke to the court employee who accompanied Niazi to this meeting. Before they left, Ropel went over to Niazi and shook his hand. He told Niazi that mistakes had been made. We're all human, he said. I'm sorry.
请记住，罗佩尔是那个据称威胁过尼亚兹、后来逮捕了他，然后在法庭上作证说他是社会威胁的特工。我采访了陪同尼亚兹参加这次会面的法院员工。在他们离开前，罗佩尔走过来与尼亚兹握手。他告诉尼亚兹，犯了错误。我们都是人，他说。对不起。
Sam Black. He's a documentary filmmaker in New York. Our program today is produced today by Lisa Pollak with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menhivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our office manager. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddes. Production help from Tarek Fouda.
萨姆·布莱克。他是纽约的一名纪录片导演。我们今天的节目是由丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）与亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·门希瓦尔（Jonathan Menhivar）、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）共同制作的。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗伯·格德斯（Rob Geddes）提供了音乐帮助。塔里克·福达（Tarek Fouda）提供了制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Trevor Aaronson, the journalist Sam interviewed about the 500 FBI cases, has a book about those cases, The Terror Factory . It's coming out in January.
萨姆采访的关于500起FBI案件的记者特雷弗·阿伦森有一本关于这些案件的书，《恐怖工厂》（The Terror Factory）。它将于一月出版。
We finished mixing and assembling today's radio program on what has been a terrible day for all of us here at This American Life. Today we learned that our friend David Rakoff died. Regular listeners have heard him many, many times on our show. His voice is one of the defining voices of our program, and he's been with us almost from the beginning.
我们今天完成并剪辑了今天的广播节目，对于我们这里的所有《美国生活》成员来说，今天是糟糕的一天。今天我们得知我们的朋友大卫·拉科夫（David Rakoff）去世了。常听的听众在我们的节目中听过他很多、很多次。他的声音是我们节目的标志性声音之一，他几乎从一开始就和我们在一起。
We knew that his death was coming. For months, he's been saying that he wouldn't live past August. So none of this is any surprise. But as anybody knows who's been in this situation, even when you know it's coming, it's still somehow a shock when it actually happens. It's a shock that he's gone. So here's a moment to remember him.
我们知道他的死期将近。几个月来，他一直说他活不过八月。所以这一切都不足为奇。但正如任何处于这种处境的人所知，即使你知道它即将到来，当它真正发生时，这在某种程度上仍然是一个震惊。他走了，这真是一个震惊。所以这是一个纪念他的时刻。
So we will be back next week with some of his great funny stories. And I hope you tune in for that. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who-- you may know this-- he wakes up early each morning, throws off the covers, looks at the alarm clock, takes a deep breath, and tells the world--
所以我们下周会带着他一些精彩的有趣故事回来。我希望你们届时收听。《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发。WBEZ的管理层对我们节目的监督是由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）负责的，他——你们可能知道——他每天清晨醒来，掀开被子，看看闹钟，深吸一口气，告诉世界——
5:45 AM and I am hot.
凌晨5:45，我很热。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。